Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. We live in a world in which we tiptoe along a thin line between free will and selfishness, between self-determination and narcissism, between empathy and righteousness.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告连播、抢先听全集并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告连播并访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需轻点几下即可在应用内订阅。我们生活在一个世界里，在这个世界里，我们在自由意志与自私之间、在自我决定与自恋之间、在同理心与清高正义感之间小心翼翼地走着钢丝。
Underpinning everything are these crucial questions. Who am I as an individual? And who am I as a member of a group and society? When did we begin to be as selfish as we are today? At what point did we expect to have the right to determine our own lives? When did we think it was our right to take what we wanted? Where did this us, you, me, or our collective behavior all come from? And when did we first ask the question, how can I be free? So Tom Holland, these are questions that I imagine you ask yourself all the time. Every day I leap out of bed asking those questions.
这一切的基础都是这些至关重要的问题。作为一个个体的我是谁？作为群体和社会的成员的我又是谁？我们是从什么时候开始变得像今天这样自私的？我们在什么时候开始期望拥有决定自己生活的权利？我们是在什么时候认为获取自己想要的东西是我们的权利？我们身上的这种“我们”、“你”、“我”，或者我们的集体行为，究竟都从何而来？我们又是从什么时候开始第一次提出“我该如何获得自由”这个问题的？所以，汤姆·霍兰，我想这些问题大概是你脑海中经常盘旋的吧。我每天从床上跳起来时都在问这些问题。
They're the questions posed in a preface to a wonderful new book, which we'll come to in just a second. But people often say, don't they, that we live in an age of unparalleled narcissism and um people often like to trace this back to the ideals of philosophers and writers and people who argued about the self and the individual and the kind of romantic ideal of the the poet in his garret or staring out over a mountain i mean this is very, not only is it your kind of territory because you love Lord Byron, who you believe to have been a vampire, but also... I mean, that's very much doing what you want, isn't it?
这些是一本精彩新书的前言中提出的问题，我们马上就会谈到它。但人们经常说，不是吗？我们生活在一个无与伦比的自恋时代，而且人们经常喜欢把这追溯到哲学家、作家以及那些探讨“自我”和“个体”之人的理念，以及那种阁楼里的诗人或凝视着群山沉思的诗人的浪漫主义理想——我的意思是，这不仅非常契合你的领地，因为你热爱拜伦勋爵，你认为他是个吸血鬼，而且……我的意思是，这非常符合随心所欲的作风，不是吗？
You are very much this sort of person, aren't you? I see you as a rugged individual staring out over great mountain ranges, contemplating the... That is so kind. I mean this pejoratively. So that's poor behaviour by your reckoning. Well, I'm Samuel Johnson kicking a stone. You are. He kicked a stone and refuted
你就是这种类型的人，对吧？我眼中的你就像一个粗犷的个人主义者，凝视着绵延的山脉，沉思着……你太客气了。我这话可不是好意。所以按你的标准，这就是糟糕的行为。好吧，我就是那个踢石头的塞缪尔·约翰逊。你正是如此。他踢了一块石头，驳倒了
Bishop Barclay's theory of immaterialism. So you mentioned Byron, but of course, actually, I mean, this is very German behaviour. It is German. Because the idea of romanticism, the very word romantic in the way that we use it today, originates with a group of German philosophers in the university town of Jena, basically in the 1790s. And it's the argument of my dear friend, Andrea Wolff, who award-winning historian, and despite being German, writes brilliant, brilliant English. Despite being German. Tom, what an introduction. And her latest book is Magnificent Rebels, The First Romantics and the Invention of the Self. And Andrea, when you told me about this, it must have been three, four years ago that you were planning to write a book about a bunch of philosophers in the university town of Jena, I thought that was a brave choice. Because Dominic, as a kind of philosophers in the university town of Jena, I thought that was a brave choice.
毕晓普·巴克莱的非物质主义理论。所以你提到了拜伦，但实际上，这其实是非常德国化的行为。这确实很德国化。因为浪漫主义的概念，也就是我们今天所使用的“浪漫”这个词本身，起源于1790年代左右大学城耶拿的一群德国哲学家。这也是我的好朋友安德烈亚·沃尔夫的观点，她是一位屡获殊荣的历史学家，尽管她是德国人，却写得一手极其出色的英文。尽管她是德国人。汤姆，这算什么介绍啊。她的最新力作是《壮丽的叛逆者：第一代浪漫主义者与自我的发明》。安德烈亚，当你跟我说起这件事时——那大概是三四年前吧——说你正计划写一本关于大学城耶拿的一群哲学家的书时，我觉得这是一个很大胆的选择。因为多米尼克，作为大学城耶拿的一群哲学家，我觉得这是一个很大胆的选择。
Because, Dominic, as a kind of John Bull figure, what is your attitude towards German idealist philosophers? Do you read them regularly? Are you a fan of them? Do you curl up with shelling of an evening? Yeah. I mean, when I'm on the train on the way to Molineux on a Saturday, Tom, I've often got a volume of Fichte with me, reading a bit of Hegel. Absolutely. No, I mean, I think what is absolutely fascinating, Tom, is that this is a world so unknown to English-speaking readers. So, in other words, we're in 18th century Germany.
因为，多米尼克，作为一个有点像约翰·牛津式的人物，你对德国唯心主义哲学家有什么看法？你经常读他们的书吗？你是他们的粉丝吗？你会在傍晚时分捧着谢林的书蜷缩在沙发里吗？是的。我的意思是，汤姆，当我在星期六坐火车去莫利纽克斯球场的路上时，我的包里经常装着一卷费希特，读上一小段黑格尔。完全没有。不，我的意思是，汤姆，我认为绝对迷人的是，这是一个英语读者完全陌生的世界。换句话说，我们正处于18世纪的德国。
So, Germany has not been unified yet. We are, as you say, in the era of the French Revolution. And we are talking about one of the most advanced, most civilized, most enlightened, as it were, parts of Europe. And all these people who, for many years, actually, in Britain, were seen as absolute paragons and models. Well, and direct influences on the Romantic movement here. Yeah. And since disappeared, haven't they? I think partly because of the World Wars, Tom,
所以，德国当时还没有统一。正如你所说，我们正处于法国大革命时期。我们讨论的是欧洲最先进、最文明、最开明的部分之一。在英国，多年来，所有这些人实际上都被视为绝对的楷模和典范。嗯，而且他们对这里的浪漫主义运动有着直接的影响。是的。从那以后他们就消失了，不是吗？汤姆，我想部分是因为世界大战，
they've sort of been airbrushed out. But anyway, tell me about Coleridge. Well, so Coleridge goes to study there and basically plagiarizes vast chunks of philosophy from Schelling in particular, this philosopher. And that has a huge influence on English romanticism. So the English romantics, the French romantics, American romantics, all absolutely in debt to this. And Andrea, in your introduction, you say, I mean, you express the significance of this decade, the 1790s in Jena, in very, very kind of vaunting terms, a mere blink in time, yet one of the most important decades for the shaping of the modern mind. And it has to be said that you conclusively, I think, make that case. And not only do you make that case, but you make it in an incredibly entertaining style. Because although,
他们某种程度上被淡出了历史。不过，无论如何，跟我讲讲柯勒律治吧。好的，柯勒律治去那里学习，基本上大段抄袭了特别是哲学家谢林的哲学。这对英国浪漫主义产生了巨大的影响。所以英国浪漫主义者、法国浪漫主义者、美国浪漫主义者，都绝对受惠于此。安德烈亚，你在导言中谈到，我的意思是，你用非常非常崇高的词汇来表达这个十年（即1790年代的耶拿）的重要意义：这只是历史长河中微不足道的一瞬，却是塑造现代心灵最重要的十年之一。必须承认，我认为你令人信服地论证了这一点。而且你不仅论证了这一点，你还以一种极其引人入胜的风格将其呈现出来。因为尽管，
you know, the philosophy is incredibly important, as you demonstrate, I mean, they are, they're such a bunch, they're endlessly marrying with each other, falling, falling out of each other's beds, having spats. I mean, you've written it almost as a kind of soap opera, verging at points into a sitcom. Yeah, well, you know, when if the thing is, if you write about philosophy, you need to kind of lighten it up a little bit. And, and, and I also think the problem is we see philosophy or philosophers through their works, but obviously they were people and their philosophy was a philosophy of the self. So they kind of used their own lives as a platform to try this all out. So they became quite egotistical also. So it's a book about big, big ideas about the beginning of the modern self.
你知道，正如你所展示的那样，哲学非常重要，但我的意思是，他们这群人太有意思了，他们无休止地彼此结婚、互相出轨、吵架。我的意思是，你几乎把它写成了一部肥皂剧，有时甚至有点像情景喜剧。对，你知道的，如果你写哲学的话，你需要稍微让它轻松一点。而且，我也觉得问题在于，我们是通过作品来看待哲学或哲学家的，但显然他们也是人，他们的哲学是关于自我的哲学。所以他们把自己的生活当作尝试这一切的平台。因此他们也变得相当自负。所以这是一本关于宏大思想、关于现代自我起源的书。
But it is also a soap opera with lots of sex and rock and roll and fun. And, you know, because we have thousands and thousands of letters and these are all poets, so they write really well and really gossipy. So because we have these letters, you can actually, you can enter the rooms with them. You can enter the bedroom with them. I mean, one of them wrote an erotic autobiographical novel where he basically invites the readers to watch him and his lover make love in quite explicit erotic detail. So they're philosophers, but they're also
但它也是一部充斥着大量性爱、摇滚乐和乐趣的肥皂剧。而且，你知道的，因为我们有成千上万的书信，而他们又都是诗人，所以他们写得非常棒，充满了八卦。正因为我们有这些信件，你实际上可以走进他们的房间。你可以走进他们的卧室。我的意思是，其中一人写了一部色情自传体小说，在书中他基本上邀请读者以相当露骨的色情细节观看他和情人做爱。所以他们虽然是哲学家，但也是
very flawed human beings. Well, you quote Novalis, who is the kind of the prototype of the doomed romantic poet, great poet who dies young, age of 29, I think think so the prototype for keats and jelly and all that kind of thing um and and you quote from his diary um in which he is endlessly recording his um sexual moods and his wanking and all kinds of stuff which he frames as um lewdness raged from morning into the afternoon so i know but then you if you go on, there's one where the lewd fantasy in the morning leads to an explosion in the afternoon. Oh, my word. Yes.
有着严重缺陷的凡人。好吧，你引用了诺瓦利斯的话，他是那种注定悲剧的浪漫主义诗人的原型，才华横溢却英年早逝，我想他死时才29岁，所以他是济慈、雪莱以及所有这类人物的原型，而且你还引用了他的日记，他在日记中无休止地记录着他的性情欲和手淫等等，他将这些描述为，从早到晚狂暴的淫荡。哦，天哪，是的。
So this is very much a collection of people who are not just doing philosophy, I think it's fair to say. So let's put them, Andrew, in place and in time. So we are at the end of the 18th century and we are in a place called Jena. There was a battle of Jena, which we might come to later. But first of all, so where is Jena and why should we be interested in it? So maybe I should start with Germany, just to explain a little bit where Jena is, because Jena is in Germany. So as you said in
所以这群人绝不仅仅是在做哲学研究，我觉得这样说很公允。安德烈亚，让我们把他们放到当时的地点和时间中去。我们正处于18世纪末，在一个叫做耶拿的地方。后来有一场耶拿战役，我们稍后可能会谈到。但首先，耶拿在哪里？我们为什么要对它感兴趣？所以我或许应该从德国讲起，稍微解释一下耶拿在哪里，因为耶拿在德国。正如你在
your introduction, Germany at the end of the 18th century is not a unified nation. It's a patchwork of 1500 states ranging from tiny principalities to big, you know, mighty states like Prussia and Austria. And Jena is in the Duchy of Sachse Weimar, which is in the middle of it. But the unintended advantage of this fragmentation is that censorship is basically very difficult to enforce in these little states because every state has a different set of rules. So very unlike century ruled countries like England or France. And France, England, Spain have also big, you know, their big global monarchies, powerful monarchies with a global reach through their colonies. And in Germany, everything is inward looking and splintered. So the German imagination really is fed by words and by books. And Germans
导言中所说，18世纪末的德国并不是一个统一的国家。它是一个由1500个邦国组成的拼盘，从小型的诸侯国到普鲁士和奥地利这样庞大、强大的国家应有尽有。耶拿位于萨克森-魏玛公国，正好在它的中间。但这种碎片化带来的非预期优势是，在这些小邦国里，审查制度基本上很难执行，因为每个邦国都有一套不同的规则。这与英国或法国等中央集权国家截然不同。而且法国、英国、西班牙也都是庞大的全球性君主国，是通过殖民地拥有全球影响力的强大君主国。但在德国，一切都是向内看的、支离破碎的。因此，德国人的想象力真的是由文字和书籍来滋养的。德国人
are fanatical readers. So the literacy rates in Germany are much higher than elsewhere. So Saxony and Prussia actually lead the world at the end of the 18th century. They're more universities. I was really startled to read, and a little bit embarrassed on behalf of England, I'm afraid to say, that the German book trade was four to five times larger than that in England, which isn't at all the impression that one would get from reading about Grub Street in London or something. Yeah, and everybody read in Germany. I mean, you cannot underestimate how many people read in Germany. And you have 50 universities compared to two universities in England. So ideas and arguments traveled quite easily through the German states. But then the question is, why Jena?
是狂热的读者。所以德国的识字率比其他任何地方都要高得多。因此，在18世纪末，萨克森和普鲁士实际上引领了世界。那里有更多的大学。我读到时着实吓了一跳，而且替英国感到有点尴尬，我必须说，德国的图书贸易规模竟然是英国的四到五倍，这与我们在伦敦格拉布街（Grub Street）之类的文章中所得到的印象完全不同。是的，德国每个人都在读书。我的意思是，你绝对不能低估在德国读书的人数。英国只有两所大学，而德国却有50所。因此，思想和观点在德国各邦之间传播得相当容易。但问题是，为什么偏偏是耶拿？
So Jena is this small town, four and a half thousand inhabitants. It's a university town. It's tiny, So it takes like less than 10 minutes to cross. It's headed by a pretty enlightened ruler who encourages a certain degree of openness and frankness. And but the real reason why there's more freedom in Jena and why it attracts more liberally minded people than anywhere else in Germany is the governance of the university, which once belonged to Saxony, but through complicated inheritance laws, basically nominally kind of controlled by four different Saxon dukes, no one is in charge. So what happens is every writer, every thinker who has problems with the authorities in their hometowns ends up in Jena.
所以耶拿是个小镇，只有四千五百名居民。它是一座大学城。它非常小，横穿它甚至不到10分钟。它的统治者相当开明，鼓励一定程度的坦率与直言。但耶拿之所以拥有更多的自由、并比德国其他任何地方都更能吸引思想开明之士的真正原因，在于该大学的管理体制。它曾经属于萨克森，但通过复杂的继承法，它基本上名义上受四个不同的萨克森公爵控制，没有人真正掌权。所以结果就是，任何在自己家乡与当局发生问题的作家、思想家，最后都会来到耶拿。
So it becomes this very transient place of very revolutionary minds. And I mean, for me, one great example was that it's so transient that you have a staggering amount of 25 percent, a quarter of all children born in Jena at the time of the Jena set are born out of wedlock. So there's a lot of sex going on there. Right, right. And it's a very kind of small, intimate place, isn't it? Yes. And you say again and again throughout the book that it's a place that's too small for gossip. So essentially, when people start sleeping with one another or bitching about them behind their
因此，这里成了一个充满革命思想、极具流动性的地方。而且对我来说，一个很好的例子就是，由于这种流动性惊人，当时耶拿新生儿中有高达百分之二十五（也就是四分之一）的非婚生子女。所以那里发生了很多性行为。对，对。而且这是一个非常小型、非常私密的地方，对吧？是的。你在书中反复提到，这是一个小得藏不住八卦的地方。因此，本质上，当人们开始和彼此发生性关系，或者在背后说别人闲话时，
backs, it always gets back to them. And so it's ideally suited to the swirl and drama of soap opera. Yeah, absolutely. And I think because it's so small, I mean, people walk from, you know, say from their house to the library and they cross the market town and they will meet everybody there. So there's no way you can hide that you're sleeping with someone. And then, I mean, the thing is actually they don't want to hide it. So there are quite a lot of open marriages. So you have, for example, Wilhelm von Humboldt and his wife, who their lover lives, her lover lives with the Humboldts in their house
总是会传到当事人耳朵里。所以它极其适合肥皂剧那种风起云涌的戏剧性。是的，绝对的。而且我认为因为这里太小了，人们从家里走到图书馆，会穿过集市广场，他们会遇到那里的每个人。所以你根本无法隐瞒你在和谁睡觉。而且，其实他们也并不想隐瞒。所以有很多开放式婚姻。比如，威廉·冯·洪堡和他的妻子，她的情夫就和洪堡夫妇住在一个屋檐下，
and goes very openly to all their kind of social activities. Or the Schlegel, Karoline Schlegel and or the the schlegel carolina schlegel and august wilhelm schlegel they have an open marriage um she she's quite a character we can talk about her later so so it's very open and no one really seems to mind and i think also we sometimes forget it's the victorians who made it all so kind of rigid the 18th century was quite um open-minded about stuff like that. So let's talk about the big figure.
并且非常公开地参与他们所有的社交活动。或者施莱格尔，卡罗琳·施莱格尔和奥古斯特·威廉·施莱格尔，他们拥有开放式婚姻，她是一个相当有性格的人，我们稍后可以谈谈她。所以这一切非常公开，似乎没有人真正在意。而且我也觉得，有时候我们忘了，是维多利亚时代的人把一切变得那么死板，18世纪对这种事其实相当开明。所以我们来谈谈这个大人物吧。
So the big figure who is the sort of godfather, if you like. So he's from a slightly older generation. He is the one German writer, I would guess, that most of the listeners to this podcast will have heard of, that can be guaranteed to have heard of, even if you haven't read his stuff.
所以这个重要人物就像是教父一样的角色，如果你这么认为的话。他来自稍年长的一代。我猜，在所有德国作家中，这个播客的大多数听众都听说过他，甚至就算你没读过他的作品，也必定能保证听说过他。
And that is Johann Wolfgang von Goethe. So Goethe, whose book The Sorrows of Young Goethe had been the great kind of hit, I guess, of the 1770s. And he doesn't live in Jena, but he comes and visits and he is the sort of, he's the big man, isn't he? Yes. So Goethe is the literary superstar in Germany. I mean, he was catapulted to international fame through his novel, The Sorrows of Young Werther, which is a novel about a lovelorn man who commits suicide and who, talking about Byron, there's Byron later jokes to Goethe that Werther encouraged a kind of wave of suicides. And Byron later jokes to Goethe that Werther encouraged a kind of wave of suicides. And Byron said to Goethe that Werther has killed more young men than Napoleon.
他就是约翰·沃尔夫冈·冯·歌德。歌德的书《少年维特的烦恼》大概是1770年代的超级畅销书。他不住在耶拿，但他会来这里访问，他就是那种大人物，对吧？是的。歌德是德国的文学巨星。他的小说《少年维特的烦恼》讲述了一个失恋男子自杀的故事，这让他一举成名，说到拜伦，拜伦后来曾向歌德开玩笑说，维特引发了一股自杀潮。拜伦后来对歌德说，维特引发了一股自杀潮。拜伦还对歌德说，维特杀死的人比拿破仑还要多。
So young men would run around in the Werther costume, in the Werther uniform. So Goethe writes this as a young man. And then in the 1790s, when theina set kind of happens he's he's older he's in his mid-40s and fatter yeah he has a very bulging belly which he buttons in with like stripy and flowery waist so not very young furter he's no he's like he reminds me of bilbo backins oddly tom yes yes the bulging fan of uh colored waistcoats. Anyway, that's a ludicrous excursion. Sorry, Andrea. No worries.
所以年轻人们会穿着维特的服装、维特的制服到处跑。歌德在年轻时写了这部作品。然后到了1790年代，“耶拿圈子”形成的时候，他已经年龄更大了，处于四十岁出头，而且胖了。是的，他有一个凸起的肚子，用条纹和花卉图案的背心把它扣起来。所以一点也不像年轻的维特。他不，他莫名其妙地让我想起了比尔博·巴金斯，汤姆。是的，是的，那个突出的、五颜六色的背心。总之，这是一段荒谬的题外话。抱歉，安德烈亚。没关系。
So by the time the Yen Eset arrives, he's very much part of the government of the small duchy of Saxo Weimar. He's the privy councillor. So that's where the von comes from. So he's been raised to the aristocracy. Exactly, exactly. And he's in charge of the mines and the theatre.
所以当耶拿圈子形成时，他已经是萨克森-魏玛小公国政府的重要成员了。他是枢密顾问。这就是他名字里“冯（von）”的由来。所以他已经被提升为贵族了。没错，没错。他负责矿山和剧院。
So he's very much part of the establishment. But he's also failed to produce anything remarkable for quite a few years. He's very depressed about the political situation, about the French wars. And he focuses on scientific experiments. He's really into botany and comparative anatomy. So he dissects like frogs and caterpillars and everything.
所以他很大程度上是建制派的一部分。但他也有好几年没有产出什么了不起的作品了。他对政治局势、对法国战争感到非常沮丧。他把精力集中在科学实验上。他非常痴迷于植物学和比较解剖学。所以他解剖青蛙、毛毛虫以及各种东西。
So he's feeling not great in the mid-1790s. And then in 1794, he bumps, after a botanical lecture, he bumps into Jena's most famous inhabitant, Friedrich Schiller, who is Germany's most famous playwright. He became famous through his revolutionary play, The Robbers. So they start talking with each other and it becomes really the most extraordinary literary friendship in Germany. These two are very, very different. So Schiller, for example, is this tall, gaunt, perpetually ill man who can only write when he has a drawer full of rotten apples in his desk. Yeah, that's such an odd behavior. It is, isn't it? He keeps very erratic
所以他在1790年代中期感觉不太好。然后到了1794年，在听了一场植物学讲座后，他偶然遇到了耶拿最著名的居民弗里德里希·席勒，他是德国最著名的剧作家。他因其革命性戏剧《强盗》而成名。于是他们开始交谈，这成为了德国历史上最非凡的文学友谊。这两个人非常非常不同。比如席勒，是一个身材高瘦、长期生病的人，只有当书桌抽屉里塞满烂苹果时才能写作。是的，这种行为太奇怪了。确实如此，对吧？他的工作时间非常不规律，
hours, work hours, because he is an insomniac, he's ill. And so he's this very tense person. And Goethe is this kind of rosy cheek, kind of, you know, Bill by Baggins. Tom, did you not read this section, Finding Uncanny? The tall, gaunt, hypochondriac Schiller. Tall, thin, almost gaunt with reddish long hair and pale, blotchy skin. His face was dominated by a large nose and protruding cheekbones he looked as ill as he felt and he's always wittering on about cricket he can't sleep in the middle of the night because where the words for his next book are going to come and then girter in many ways the greater man girter who is the man who's sold out who's taken the uh sort of a stouter figure admittedly and shorter but i mean did you not
因为他有失眠症，而且生病。所以他是一个非常紧张的人。而歌德则是一个红光满面、有点像比尔博·巴金斯的人。汤姆，你难道没有读到这一段吗？（寻找不可思议之处）高大、清瘦、疑神疑鬼的席勒。又高又瘦，几乎皮包骨头，留着红色的长发，皮肤苍白斑驳。他的面部特征是一个大鼻子和突出的颧骨，他看起来和感觉一样虚弱。而且他总是喋喋不休地谈论板球，半夜睡不着觉，因为下一本书的词句不知道从哪里蹦出来。而歌德，在很多方面更伟大，歌德是个“出卖灵魂”的人，他接受了——虽然身材更敦实、个子更矮，但我的意思是，你难道不觉得这很诡异吗？我认为那是，是的，非常奇怪，非常奇怪。把多米尼克荒谬的对比暂且搁置一边，席勒在浪漫主义行为上也有过相当糟糕的表现，不是吗？因为他在追求妻子的同时，也在追求她的姐姐，这可以说是非常拜伦式的行为，汤姆。稍微有一点，但后来他们有一桩相当传统的婚姻，当他最终决定娶这姐妹俩中的哪一个之后。所以他们非常非常不同，一个就像——歌德形容自己是一个头脑清醒的现实主义者，是的，他喜欢实验和观察，热爱他的科学。多米尼克，好吧，我不喜欢科学。
find that uncanny i think that is that yes very weird very weird um parking dominic's ludicrous comparison on one side um schiller also has uh behaved quite badly hasn't he romantically because while he's courting his wife he's also courting uh her sister so very byronic behavior tom very just a little bit but then they have a quite conventional marriage actually um when he when he when he finally decides who of the sisters he's getting married to but so they're so they're very very different so one is like a you know goethe describes himself as like a hard-headed realist and yes who likes his experiments and his observations loves his science dominic okay, I don't like science.
然后席勒则形容自己是一个唯心主义者，是一个相信思想和精神构成现实、而非物质构成现实的人。于是这两个人走到了一起，并开始合作。他们互相编辑对方的作品，互相鼓励。他们都迎来了各自生活中最具生产力的阶段，并在此时创作出了他们最伟大的一些作品。所以我把他们塑造为——因为他们年纪较大，我把他们塑造成几乎像是故事的框架。因为随后，年轻一代、那些头脑发热且疯狂的年轻一代登场了。
And then you have Schiller who describes himself as an idealist, who's someone who believes that ideas and the mind constitute reality, not matter. So those two men come together and they begin to work together. So they edit each other's work. They encourage each other. And they both enter one of their most productive phases in their lives. And they both of them produced some of their greatest work at this time. So I've kind of cast them, because they're older, I've cast them as almost like a frame to the story. Because then the younger generation, the kind of hot-headed, crazy younger generation arrives.
而令人惊奇的是，歌德被他们激进且疯狂的思想彻底注入了活力。而他们反过来又把他高高捧起。他成了他们的半神。就像他们严厉而慈爱的教父一样。所以每当他们陷入麻烦时，他都试图从中斡旋。最后他们和席勒闹翻了，而他一次又一次地试图让每个人都开心。所以有一种青春降临耶拿的感觉。
And amazingly, Goethe is absolutely invigorated by their kind of radical and mad ideas. And they, in turn, just put him on a pedestal. He becomes like their demigod. So like their kind of stern and benevolent godfather. So whenever they're in trouble, he tries to mediate. So they fall out eventually with Schiller. And he again and again tries to keep everybody happy, basically. So there's this sense of youth arriving in Jena.
而这个“老人”（44岁，在今天看来不算老，但在当时算老人）感到彻底返老还童，开始——因为魏玛距离耶拿只有15英里，他开始花越来越多时间在耶拿。有时，我的意思是，连续数周甚至数月，他在耶拿呆的时间甚至超过了他在魏玛的时间，因为他远离了宫廷，远离了宫廷职责，所以他可以在耶拿获得自由。这与魏玛截然不同。你觉得他是不是因为身边环绕着这些充满绝妙新奇想法的年轻人，而感到精力倍增、重焕生机？是的，我认为他最著名的作品是《浮士德》。他当时完全卡壳了，我是说，他被困住了，他没有写，他已经停止写作了。然后这群人来了，他感到自己再次充满生机，于是重新翻出《浮士德》开始写作。你知道，我们今天看到的《浮士德》就是他在耶拿圈子期间写作的版本，或者说其中的大部分内容。你谈到了这群年轻后生们的到来。我们可以看看其中的几位吗？你认为谁在点燃导火索方面最重要？
And this kind of old man, 44, not very old in our days, but then old man feels completely rejuvenated and begins because Weimar is only 15 miles away from Jena, and he begins to spend more and more time in Jena. Sometimes, I mean, weeks and months on end, sometimes he spends more time in Jena than he's actually in Weimar, because he's away from the court, he's away from, you know, his court duties, so he can be free in Jena. It's very, very different to Weimar. And do you think he feels invigorated, reinvigorated by being surrounded by all these
那肯定是费希特。很抱歉，我们现在不得不谈论一位哲学家了。不过他也是个相当有性格的人物，不是吗？他叫约翰·戈特利布·费希特，对吧？是的，他叫约翰·戈特利布·费希特，他相当有性格。所以你必须想象这样一个家伙。与其说他像赛马，不如说他更像一头公牛，他身材魁梧、肌肉发达，他在讲课时总是穿着
young people having brilliant novel ideas? Yeah, I think his most famous work is Faust. And he had completely got, I mean, he was stuck. He didn't write, he hadn't, he'd stopped writing it. And then this kind of gang arrives, and he feels so kind of alive again, and he unpacks Faust again, and he kind of writes it. And you know, the Faust we see today is the Faust he wrote, or large parts, large chunk he wrote during the time of the Jena set. You talk about the arrival of this kind of gang of young guns. Could we look at some of them? So who would you say is the most significant in terms of kind of lighting the touch paper with this?
马靴，带着马刺，手里挥舞着皮鞭，他那反复无常的脾气让人闻风丧胆。他真的用鞭子吗？他是把它当道具，还是说如果有人睡着了他就抽他们，到底是怎么回事？我没有读到过任何关于他鞭打人的记录。所以我想这大概只是他进门时带着的道具。但是，费希特身上没有半点温和可言。他雷霆大怒、大喊大叫、出言不逊、跺脚走路而不是正常走路。他吃鼻烟而不是吸鼻烟。
It would be Fichte. I'm sorry to say we're going to have to talk about philosopher now. Well, he's quite a character though, isn't he? So he's Johann Gottlieb Fichte, that's his name? Yeah, he's Johann Gottlieb Fichte, and he was quite a character. So you have to imagine this guy. So he's more bull than a race horse he's quite kind of sturdily built and muscular and he gives his lectures um in his
我的意思是，他就是这样一个人。这也是另一个奇怪、非常奇怪的细节。而且他如此受欢迎。他的学生称他为哲学界的拿破仑，因为他彻底革新了我们对自我的思考方式。他是如此受欢迎，以至于他的阶梯教室座无虚席。学生们甚至站在梯子上，通过窗户往里看。
riding boots with spurs and whip in hand and he's feared for his volatile temperament and does he use the whip i mean is using it as a prop or is he kind of you know people fall asleep he lashes them or what's going on i have going on? I have not read anything. So I think it was just like he would just come in. Yeah, a prop. But he's, so there's nothing gentle about Fichte at all. So he thunders, he shouts, he insults, he stomps rather than walks. He eats his snuff tobacco rather than inhaling it.
我的意思是，耶拿一半的学生都来听他的课，因为他所做的是——在一个整个欧洲都被专制主义铁蹄控制的时代，费希特将自我注入了最令人心潮澎湃的力量：自由意志和自我决定。对于我们来说，这听起来可能没那么激动人心，因为我们太习惯于通过自我意识的棱镜来看待世界了，但在当时，这是一个如此革命性的想法。所以他基本上是在说，没有上帝赋予的真理。你知道的，我们所知道的一切，唯一的确定性是世界是通过自我来体验的。他说，自我设定其自身的存在，这意味着自我基本上将自身带入了存在。不仅如此，通过最初这个强大的行动，它也将外部世界带入了
I mean, he's just like this. That is another weird, very weird detail. So he's, and he's so popular. His students call him the Bonaparte of philosophy because he revolutionized the way we think about us. And he's so popular that his auditorium is packed. The students are standing on ladders, looking through the window.
存在，至少在我们的脑海中是这样的。所以它并没有创造世界，它不创造物质世界，但它创造了我们对外部世界的认知，而这改变了一切，这就是现代自我的开端。因为他所做的是，他的思想既简单又激进，它宣称自我主宰着世界——统治这个世界的不是国王、女王或神明，而是我们。是我们的心灵。这简直是一个爆炸性的思想，现在虽然很难理解，但在当时绝对是震撼人心的。来自欧洲各地的学生
I mean, half of the students of Jena come to his lectures, because what he does is, so at a time when Europe is held, most of Europe is held in the einfest of absolutism, Fichte imbues the self with the most thrilling of all powers, with free will and self-determination. So that might not sound so exciting for us because we are so used to kind of seeing the world through the prism of our own self, but it was such a revolutionary idea then. And so he says, basically, there are no God-given truth. You know, everything that we know, the only certainty is that the world is experienced through the self. And he says, the self posits its own being, which means the self basically brings itself into existence. And not only that, through this initial powerful act, it also brings the external world into
纷纷来到耶拿师从费希特。我的意思是，这里有一种毫不妥协的个人主义，绝对毫不妥协的个人主义，对吧？“唯有我的意志，将在宇宙的废墟之上傲然无畏地漂浮。”所以，如果说得严厉一点，费希特是现代自恋之父吗？这样说会不会太严厉了？我是不是表现得太像《每日邮报》了？嗯，算是也不是。它确实曾被这样使用过，但他从未意图对自我进行自恋式的颂扬，恰恰相反。费希特所说的是，自由总是与我们的道德义务紧密交织在一起。
existence, at least in our mind. So it doesn't bring the world, it doesn't create the world, but it creates our knowledge of the external world and that changes everything that is the beginning of the modern self because what he does is his ideas as simple as it is radical it says that the self is the supreme ruler of the world so the self not kings or queens or gods rule this world. It's us. It's our mind. And that is just, I mean, that's an explosive idea, which is really difficult to understand now, but it was mind-blowing. I mean, students from all over Europe
对他而言，这种理念是：自由赋予了我们如何行动和表现的选择权。它将我们从贪婪、饥饿和恐惧这些低级本能中提升出来。自由总是伴随着它的孪生兄弟，那就是道德责任。最近大流行期间有一个很好的例子。我们不得不做出决定：我该如何过上有意义的生活，既能追求梦想（即自由意志），又能在道德上成为一个好人？所以在疫情期间，我们数百万人放弃了基本的权利和自由，因为他们相信这些不去看望朋友和家人的严厉规定是为了更大的利益。但我们中的一些人没有这样做，因为他们说我们的个人
came to Jena to study under Fichte. I mean, there's a kind of unrepentant individualism, absolutely unrepentant individualism to it, isn't there? My will alone shall float audaciously and boldly over the wreckage of the universe so i mean if you were being harsh is fichte the kind of father of modern narcissism is that too am i being too too daily male about it well yes or no so it it has been used like this but it was never he never intended a narcissistic celebration of the self at all, quite the opposite. So what Fichte said was that freedom is always closely interwoven with our moral obligations.
自由更重要。我认为正是这种平衡的艺术，这种自由意志令人惊叹的可能性与自私的陷阱之间的张力，是我们至今仍在继续维持的平衡。所以，安德烈亚，这就是“我”哲学（Ich philosophy），“我”的哲学，“自我”的哲学。我的意思是，我本来以为这不可避免地会更吸引外向的人。如果你被告知是你的个人、你的自我创造了现实，我本来以为这会更吸引像费希特那样穿着马靴、挥舞马鞭在各处跺脚的人。你觉得这样说公平吗？我不同意这种看法。汤姆，如果你是个内向的人，花很多
So for him, it was this idea that freedom gives us the choice in how to act and behave. It elevates us over our base instincts of greed and hunger and fear. Freedom always comes with its twin, which is moral duty. And there's a great example very recently in the pandemic about this. So we have to make this decision. How can I live a meaningful life, where I pursue my dreams, which is the, you know, free will, and be morally a good person. So in the pandemic, millions of us gave up their basic rights and freedoms, because they believe these draconian rules of not seeing our friends and family, that was for the greater good. But some of us didn't't because they said our personal
时间独自思考自己，难道你不是更容易被这种哲学吸引吗？比起一个以他人为中心的人，我本来会这么认为的。嗯，这与另一个问题联系在一起，那就是这是一个充满泰坦式壮举的时代，尤其是法国。这是拿破仑的时代。拿破仑在某种程度上可以说是“我”哲学的化身，通过实现自我来创造现实。但德国是四分五裂的。而且正如你所说，耶拿的自由在某种程度上也是其无能的指数。难道不也存在这样一种感觉吗：对于像费希特以及聚集在他周围的其他哲学家来说，为这种哲学做出宏大的宣称是非常重要的？因为在某种程度上，他们（你知道的，
liberties are more important. And I think it's this balancing act, this tension between the breathtaking possibilities of free will and the pitfalls of selfishness, which is a balancing act we still continue to this day. So Andrea, it's the ich philosophy, the I philosophy, the me philosophy. I mean, inevitably, I would have thought going to appeal more to extroverts. If you're being told it's your own individual, it's your own self that creates reality. That I would have thought is a philosophy that would appeal more to someone who, as Victor was, was stomping around with his riding crop and boots. Would you say that's fair? I don't't agree with that I think surely aren't you more likely to be if you're an introvert Tom and you
他们并没有扬帆远航去埃及，也没有横扫欧洲或做任何类似的事情，他们只是坐在阶梯教室里。从某种意义上说，18世纪末德国人的刻板印象几乎与普鲁士人乃至纳粹催生出的刻板印象截然相反，18世纪的德国人是梦想家。从某种程度上说，这是一种试图赋予这种梦想以尊严的尝试，难道你不能这么说吗？如果你非常严厉、非常没有同情心，如果你想这样看的话——其实我会回到法国大革命，因为在法国发生的事情，法国大革命是一个如此庞大、至关重要的
spend a lot of time on your own thinking about yourself aren't you more likely to be drawn to that philosophy I would have said than if you're an other centered person well so that ties in with another question which is that this is a time of titanic deeds, particularly in France. And it's the age of Napoleon. Napoleon kind of, in a sense, is the exemplification of the ick philosophy, creating reality through the realization of his own self. But Germany is fragmented. And Jena, as you said, the freedom in a way is also the index of its impotence. And isn't there also a sense in which it's important to someone like Fichte and then to the other philosophers who gather around him to make great claims for this philosophy? Because in a sense, they, you know,
事件，它影响了欧洲几乎所有人。但当法国革命者宣布人生而平等时，他们承诺了一种建立在思想和自由力量之上的社会秩序。我认为正是那一刻，哲学走出了精深思想的象牙塔，进入了普通人的头脑。所以这是一场证明思想比任何武器或国王女王的力量都要强大的革命。我认为这赋予了心灵如此巨大的力量，以至于我们今天倾向于（我认为这是看待浪漫主义的错误方式）把他们看作那种落魄的、梦想的、忧郁的类型。第一代浪漫主义者根本不是那样的。对他们而言，这是一个非常、非常复杂、庞大且充满活力的概念，与那种孤独的人
they're not sailing to Egypt or storming across Europe or doing anything they are, sitting in lecture halls. And in a sense, the stereotype of the German in the late 18th century is almost the opposite of the one that is given birth to as a result of the Prussians and then the Nazis, that the Germans in the 18th century are dreamers. And in a way, this is an attempt to to kind of dignify that dreaming couldn't you say that if you're being very very harsh very unsympathetic if you if you want to see it like this i would actually go back to the french revolution because what happened in france the french revolution is such a massive pivotal um event that it affects almost everybody in europe but when the french revolutionaries declare that all men are equal,
站在月光下的森林里、凝视着云层之类的形象毫无关系。对他们来说，浪漫主义诗歌是一个有生命的有机体，它超越了各个学科，他们将诗歌（取其古希腊语意）置于核心，这意味着生产性和创造性。因此，他们想要将整个世界浪漫化，这意味着将艺术与科学、人类与自然结合起来。所以这是一个复杂得多的概念。他们将想象力提升为心灵的最高机能。几个世纪以来，想象力在哲学中一直被赋予次要的地位。它曾被视为可疑之物。它有点像阻碍真相，被认为不可靠。塞缪尔·
they promise a social order that is built on the power of ideas and freedom. And I think that is the moment when philosophy leaves the ivory tower of rarefied thought and arrives in the minds of ordinary people. So this is a revolution that proves that ideas are stronger than any weapon or mites of kings and queens. And I think that gives the mind such a great power that I think we tend today, and I think it's the wrong way of seeing romanticism, we think of these kind of like forlorn, dreamy, broody kind of type of people. That's not what the first romantics were about at all. For them, this was a very, very complex, unwieldy and dynamic concept that has nothing to do with the kind of the lone figure
约翰逊称其为“放荡的心智机能”。而他们走出来说：“不，不，不，不，不。想象力才是我们理解世界的方式。”但这并不意味着他们背叛了理性。他们只是做出了补充。所以他们说：“我们想要将科学诗意化。”或者像弗里德里希·施莱格尔所说：“我想让欧几里得变得可以被歌唱。”所以这里有一种创造更宏大事物的宏大愿景。
standing in a moonlit kind of forest kind of, you know, looking over the clouds or something like that. This was something where they said, romantic poetry is a living organism and it transcended disciplines and they put poetry in the ancient Greek meaning at its center, which meant productive and creative. So they wanted to romanticize the whole world and that meant bringing together the arts and the sciences, humankind and nature. So it's something much more complicated. And what they do is they elevate imagination as the highest faculty of the mind. So imagination had been seen, you know, had been kind of given a subordinate role in philosophy for centuries. It was kind of regarded with suspicion. It kind of like hit the, it kind of obscured the truth. It was unreliable. Samuel
而后来的浪漫主义者把这一切彻底搞砸了。好吧，你谈到了浪漫主义。我想我们现在应该休息一下。等我们回来后，我们要来看看那个最早创造出我们今天所使用的“浪漫”一词的人、他的妻子、他的兄弟以及各种恶作剧。所以我们会在休息后探讨这些。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、
Johnson called it a licentious faculty. And they came along and said, no, no, no, no, no. Imagination is how we understand the world. But that didn't mean that they turned against reason. They just added it. So what they said is like, we want to poeticize the sciences. Or Friedrich Schlieger said, I want to make Euclid singable. So there's this sense of creating something much bigger.
评论以及八卦爆料的好去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告连播、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。我们正在讨论浪漫主义的起源，特别是耶拿小镇的德国浪漫主义者。在休息之前，安德烈亚，汤姆曾许诺我们会探讨“浪漫主义”一词的起源。据我所知，它始于一位诗人兼翻译家，奥古斯特·威廉·施莱格尔。
And it's the later romantics who just messed it all up, basically. Okay. Well, you talk about romanticism. I think we should take a break now. And then when we come back, we should look at the man who first coins the word romantic in the sense that we use it today, his wife, his brother, and all kinds of shenanigans. So we will look at that after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
你能给我们讲讲他的事迹吗？所以这就是奥古斯特·威廉·施莱格尔和弗里德里希·施莱格尔兄弟俩。奥古斯特·威廉·施莱格尔总是衣着完美、打理得一丝不苟，有点学究气；而他的弟弟则是个疯狂的热血头子，自称为“独裁批评家”，也就是一个笔锋如同法国断头台一样锐利的文学评论家。他们着手
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the origins of Romanticism and specifically the German Romantics for the town of Jena. And before the break, Andrea, Tom was promising that we would get into the origins of the term Romanticism. And it begins, I believe, with a poet and translator, August Wilhelm Schlegel.
攻击文学建制派。他们是通过一本名为《雅典娜神庙》的文学杂志来做到这一点的——一本他们宣称要具有“崇高无礼”特性的杂志，所以这是最重要的事情。正是在《雅典娜神庙》的页面中，他们第一次使用了
So would you like to tell us a bit about him? So it's August Wilhelm Schlegel and Friedrich Schlegel. So they're two brothers um one August Wilhelm Schlegel was always perfectly dressed and perfectly groomed bit pedantic and his brother was this kind of like crazy hothead who called himself a dictator critic which is a literary critic with a pen as sharp as the french guillotines and they set out um to attack the literary establishment and they did that with a magazine a literary magazine called the athenaeum um a magazine which they said they wanted to be of sublime impertinence so that was like the most important thing and it is in the in the pages of the a the Athenaeum that they first used the term romantic
具有全新文学含义的“浪漫”一词。所以别管柯勒律治和英国浪漫主义者了。历史上第一次以这种方式使用“浪漫”一词，其实是在德国。是的，我们承认这一点。他们将浪漫主义推向了国际运动的舞台。这是他们的知识分子意图。奥古斯特·威廉·施莱格尔也是一位才华横溢的翻译家，他与妻子一起翻译了16部莎士比亚戏剧，完成了第一部德语诗体译本，至今仍是标准版本。令人惊叹的是，他出版的关于莎士比亚的讲座，
in its new literary meaning. So forget Coleridge and the English romantics. The first time romantic has been used in this way was actually in Germany. Yeah, we acknowledge that. They launched romanticism as an international movement. And they were, so that's their kind of intellectual intention. And August Wilhelm Schlegel was also a brilliant translator who together with his wife translated 16 Shakespeare plays, the first German verse translation, which to this day is the standard edition. And amazingly, his published lectures on Shakespeare,
很大程度上受到了他与妻子讨论的启发，随后竟然在英国复兴了莎士比亚，信不信由你。好吧，感谢德国。威廉· Wordsworth 曾说过，一位德国批评家正确地教导了我们如何正确思考莎士比亚。所以他们实际上是一群非常重要的人。因为这就是笑话所在，不是吗？德国语版的翻译非常好，而英语翻译其实也不赖。好吧，我必须说，我真的很喜欢——我的意思是，我住在英国。我在这里住了将近30年。我总是读英文的东西。
which were very much informed by his discussion with his wife, then resurrected Shakespeare in England, believe it or not. Well, thank you, Germany. William Wordsworth said that a German critic taught us correctly how to think correctly about Shakespeare. So they are actually quite an important bunch of people. Because that's the joke, isn't it? That the German version is very good and the English translation of it isn't bad as well. Well, I have to say, I mean, I really like, I mean, I live in England. I have lived here for almost 30 years. I always read English stuff.
这些翻译很大程度上受到了他与妻子讨论的影响，然后信不信由你，莎士比亚在英国复活了。好吧，谢谢你，德国。威廉·华兹华斯曾说过，一位德国评论家正确地教导了我们如何正确地思考莎士比亚。所以他们实际上是一群非常重要的人。因为这就是那个笑话，不是吗？德国的版本非常好，而它的英文翻译也不错。嗯，我必须说，我的意思是，我真的很喜欢，我的意思是，我住在英国。我在这里住了将近30年。我总是阅读英国的东西。
But German Shakespeare performances are pretty good. I think I almost prefer them to the English ones. Oh, I'm hanging myself out of the window. That's absolutely fine. So, Andrea, you mentioned Schlegel's wife, who is the co-translator on this. And she is an extraordinary woman. And in a way, she seems to be the beating heart of the soap opera, the sitcom, however you want to frame it. I mean, she's a remarkable figure, isn't she?
不过德国的莎士比亚演出相当不错。我想我几乎更喜欢德国的版本，而不是英国的版本。哦，我在自找麻烦呢。这完全没问题。那么，安德烈，你提到了施莱格尔的妻子，她也是这套作品的共同译者。她是一个非凡的女性。从某种程度上讲，她似乎是这场肥皂剧、情景喜剧——无论你怎么称呼它——的核心灵魂。我的意思是，她是一个了不起的人物，对吧？
So just tell us about her. So let me introduce her properly with all her names. She's Karoline Michaelis Böhmer Schlegel Schelling. So she carries the name of her father and her three husbands. And she is, as you said, she's at the heart of this story. She was born in 1763. She was the daughter of a very famous German scholar. She was raised on a diet on literature, poetry and politics. She was the daughter of a very famous German scholar. She was raised on a diet on literature, poetry, and politics. She was beautiful, educated, fiercely independently minded. She married young, was a widow by the age of 24, then hung out with the German revolutionaries, was then imprisoned by the Prussians for being a sympathizer with the French Revolution.
给我们讲讲她吧。那我来用她所有的名字正式介绍一下她。她是卡罗琳·米海利斯·伯默·施莱格尔·谢林。她冠有她父亲以及三位丈夫的姓氏。正如你所说，她处于这个故事的核心。她出生于1763年。她是一位非常著名的德国学者的女儿。她在文学、诗歌和政治的熏陶下长大。她是一位非常著名的德国学者的女儿。她在文学、诗歌和政治的熏陶下长大。她美丽、有教养、有着极其独立的思想。她很早就结婚了，24岁时便成了寡妇，后来和德国革命者混在一起，由于同情法国大革命，随后被普鲁士人关进监狱。
And then not only that, imprisoned, she discovered that she was pregnant after a one-night stand with an 18-year-old French soldier. So quite something at a time when it was scandalous behavior if you were just on your own in the room with a man. Then after her imprisonment, she kind of zigzagged through Germany, was treated as an outcast. And then August Wilhelm Schlegel came along. I mean, men just fell for her. So he was in love with her. He married her, gave her a new name. And with that, a new beginning
不仅如此，在入狱期间，她发现自己和一名18岁的法国士兵一夜情后怀孕了。在那个年代，如果一个女人独自和男人共处一室就会被视为丑闻，这绝对是一件大事。出狱后，她在德国各地辗转，被当成社会弃儿。接着，奥古スト·威廉·施莱格尔出现了。我的意思是，男人们都为她倾倒。他爱上了她。他娶了她，给了她一个新的名字，也由此开启了她的新生活。
and took her to Jena in 1796, where she really became the heart of the Jena set and not the muse. She's not just the muse. She's much, much more important. Participant. Yeah, so she does the kind of more traditional thing where she creates the physical space for them where they all meet
并在1796年把她带到了耶拿，在那里她真正成为了耶拿派的心脏，而不仅仅是缪斯。她不只是个缪斯。她要重要得多、重要得多。她是参与者。对，所以她做那种更传统的事，为他们创造一个实体空间，让他们所有人都能聚在一起
and work together and party but she's also a razor sharp critic who dissects poetry and plays and essays with deep deep knowledge and her husband and her friends begin to rely on her literary and analytical mind she She is the editor of the Athenaeum. So she takes the role of the editor. She writes reviews under her husband's name. I mean, many, many, many. And she translates together with her husband, the 16 Shakespeare plays, which of course was never acknowledged. So her name is not on any of these. Yeah, I just wanted to ask about that. So what are the possibilities for a highly educated, highly intelligent woman in Jena at the end of the 18th century? Does she have to do it all through
共同工作、举行派对，但她也是一个眼光极其犀利的评论家，能以极其深厚的知识剖析诗歌、戏剧和散文。她的丈夫和朋友们开始依赖她的文学和分析头脑。她是《雅典娜神庙》杂志的编辑。所以她承担了编辑的角色。她以她丈夫的名义写了许多、许多、许多评论。而且她和丈夫一起翻译了16部莎士比亚戏剧，这些当然从未得到过承认。所以她的名字没有出现在任何这些作品上。是的，我正想问这个。那么，对于18世纪末耶拿的一个受过高等教育、极具智慧的女性来说，她有哪些可能性？她难道必须完全通过
sort of, as it were, using her husband as a vehicle? I mean, what do people think of such an articulate, emboldened woman? So it was difficult. So most women published either anonymously or under that name of their of their husbands. There were a few who did not. But I think Carolina chose purposefully not to put her name on there because she was really famous in German for being this revolutionary whore. So it would have been not a good, you know, strategy financially to do that. But it, I mean, Schiller, for example, he had another magazine, and he published quite a lot of female writers, but all of them anonymously. So most women would not put their name on there. It changed. I mean, it changes. There are a few who later do this. but it is, I mean, if there is a place in Germany, then it was Jena that you could do that.
某种程度上将她的丈夫作为媒介来做事吗？我的意思是，人们是如何看待这样一个口齿伶俐、大胆无畏的女性的？所以这很艰难。大多数女性要么匿名发表作品，要么用她们丈夫的名字发表。也有少数没有这样做。但我认为卡罗琳是有意选择不在上面署名的，因为她在德国名声很不好，被视为这个革命荡妇。因此，从经济角度来看，在上面署名绝对不是一个好策略。不过，比如说席勒，他有另一本杂志，发表了相当多的女性作家的作品，但全都是匿名的。所以大多数女性都不会在上面署名。后来情况变了。我是说，确实变了。后来有少数人这样做了，但如果在德国真有什么地方能让人这么做，那非耶拿莫属。
So Friedrich Schlegel, for example, his lover is the divorced Dorothea Veidt. And she's a writer and she writes a novel, but she also publishes it under the name of her husband. It's a very, very common thing to do. So Friedrich Schlegel, younger brother of August Wilhelm Schlegel, and this is why the sitcom element starts to come in. So inevitably, he meets Caroline and he, I mean, he quite fancies her, doesn't he? Yeah. So he's younger. I mean, she really has a thing for younger men. There's a moment when she has an affair with the 12-year-old younger Friedrich Schelling. I'm sorry that everybody's called Friedrich and then Sch at the end.
比如腓特烈·施莱格尔，他的情人是离过婚的多萝西娅·弗伊特。她是一位作家，写了一部小说，但也是以她丈夫的名义出版的。这在当时是非常非常普遍的做法。所以奥古斯特·威廉·施莱格尔的弟弟腓特烈·施莱格尔，也就是在这里，情景喜剧的元素开始登场了。因此，他不可避免地遇到了卡罗琳，而且，我的意思是，他挺迷恋她的，对吧？是的。所以他更年轻。我的意思是，她真的对年轻男性情有独钟。有一次她和比她小12岁的腓特烈·谢林有了婚外情。很抱歉每个人都叫腓特烈，而且最后都是sch开头的发音。
Yeah. It's really confusing. Two Schlegels. No, three Schlegels. And then there's Friedrich Schiller and a Schelling. Schiller and a Schelling. Yes. It's very complicated.
是的。这真的让人很混淆。两个施莱格尔。不，三个施莱格尔。然后还有一个腓特烈·席勒和一个谢林。席勒和一个谢林。是的。这太复杂了。
So Friedrich Schlegel falls in love with Karoline, but then kind of steps back because his brother had first fallen in love. Yeah, so it's all these kind of siblings falling in love with, you know, the same person and stuff. There seems to be a running theme. Well, I would say, I mean, so the Schlegel brothers and Karoline and Dorothea Veit, who's the lover of Friedrich Schlegel, they all live together in one house. And I would really call that the first German commune. I mean, that's where it all started, basically. Right. Because they all, youel, they all lived together in one house. And I would really call that the first German commune. I mean, that's where it all started, basically. Right.
所以腓特烈·施莱格尔爱上了卡罗琳，但随后又退缩了，因为他哥哥先爱上了她。是的，所以这就是各种兄弟爱上同一个人之类的戏码。这似乎是个贯穿始终的主题。嗯，我想说的是，施莱格尔兄弟俩、卡罗琳以及作为腓特烈·施莱格尔情人的多萝西娅·弗伊特，他们全都住在同一所房子里。我真的会把那称为德国的第一个公社。我的意思是，基本上一切都是从那里开始的。没错。因为他们所有人都，你知道的，他们全都住在同一所房子里。我真的会把那称为德国的第一个公社。我的意思是，基本上一切都是从那里开始的。没错。
Because they all, you know, they all lived together. And Friedrich Schlegel, he writes these fragments where he says, like, you know, how could anyone have anything against, like, a marriage, a cadre? So it's a very, I mean, I've not found any letters that indicate that they had, like, a foursome or something like that. But you have August Wilhelm and Karoline being married in their open marriage. And then a few years in, she falls in love with the 12 year old, 12 year younger Friedrich Schelling.
因为他们所有人都，你知道的，他们都住在一起。腓特烈·施莱格尔写过一些短文，在里面他说，你知道的，怎么会有人反对婚姻、反对核心家庭呢？所以这非常——我的意思是，我没有发现任何信件表明他们有过四人行或类似的事情。但奥古斯特·威廉和卡罗琳维持着开放式婚姻。然后在几年后，她爱上了比她小12岁的腓特烈·谢林。
I was gonna say he's not 12 years old. That would be very precocious. He was 12 years younger. Well, you know, Novalis fell in love with a 12 year old. Well, we'll come to Novalis in a minute. And then and then August Wilhelm doesn't really mind because he has lovers also. So it's all, you know, very open and very casual. Right. So let's just come to Novalis, who is the archetype of the romantic poet, because he dies young. He's a friend of Friedrich Schlegel. In fact, he dies. Friedrich Schlegel is by his bedside and he becomes the archetype of the, you know, the beautiful angel, that kind of stuff.
我本想说他可不是12岁。那可就太早熟了。他比她小12岁。不过，诺瓦利斯曾爱上过一个12岁的女孩。好吧，我们一会儿就会聊到诺瓦利斯。然后，然后奥古斯特·威廉其实并不介意，因为他自己也有情人。所以这一切，你知道的，都非常开放，非常随性。没错。那我们来谈谈诺瓦利斯，他是浪漫主义诗人的原型，因为他英年早逝。他是腓特烈·施莱格尔的朋友。事实上，他去世时，腓特烈·施莱格尔就守在他的病床边，他也因此成为了那种美丽天使般的原型，诸如此类。
But actually, in some ways, he's a more conventional figure than any of these kind of philosophers hanging out in their commune, isn't he? Because he's he's basically running a load of mines. Yeah, well, he's the only one who's an aristocrat. So he comes from a privileged background, but the family doesn't have a lot of money. They just have basically their lineage. And so he runs the mines together with his father, the salt mines. So he is the only one actually who has a proper job compared to the others.
但事实上，在某些方面，他比任何这些在公社里游荡的哲学家都要传统得多，不是吗？因为他基本上在管理着一大堆矿井。是的，嗯，他是唯一一个贵族。所以他出身特权阶层，但家里并没有多少钱。他们拥有的基本上只有门第。所以他和父亲一起经营矿山，盐矿。因此，与其他人相比，他是唯一一个真正拥有正经工作的人。
And so he studies in Jena and then in Leipzig, where he meets Friedrich Schlegel. They become like best friends. And then Novalis is pretty obsessed with Fichte's philosophy of the self. Yes, because you say that he wanted to make his body disappear and become spirit alone. So, I mean, what exactly does he mean by that?
于是他在耶拿求学，然后在莱比锡遇到了腓特烈·施莱格尔。他们成了莫逆之交。然后诺瓦利斯对费希特的自我哲学相当痴迷。是的，因为你说过他想要让自己的肉体消失，只留下灵魂。所以，我的意思是，他究竟是什么意思？
No one really knows. He wants to basically transcend the kind of boundaries between the body and the mind. But what is interesting is, so he falls in love with the 12-year-old Sophie von Kuhn, which kind of makes for slightly uncomfortable reading now and then she dies after some terrible you know surgery when she's 15 and Novalis then takes Fichte's philosophy and gives it his very kind of own twist because he says well if the ich if the self can basically create the external world world and can control everything I'm going to kill myself because i want to be reunited with sophie but i'm not going to do it with a gun or rope i'm going to do it with sheer willpower um just in he believes that you know if our mind can move our body surely you know our mind should be able to like regrow an amputated arm and kill us so he is it's a little bit bonkers. But it leads him to write, I think,
没有人真正知道。他基本上想要超越肉体和精神之间的那种界限。但有趣的是，他爱上了12岁的苏菲·冯·屈恩，现在回想起来这让人感觉有点不太舒服，然后她在15岁时经历了一次可怕的手术后去世了。诺瓦利斯随后接受了费希特的哲学，并赋予了它自己独特的扭曲，因为他说，好吧，如果自我基本上可以创造外部世界并且能够控制一切，我要自杀，因为我想和苏菲团聚，但我不会用枪或绳子，我要用纯粹的意志力，嗯，就在他相信，你知道的，既然我们的精神能移动我们的身体，当然（我们的精神）也应该能够让断臂再生并杀死我们，所以他这个人有点疯狂。但这也促使他写出了我认为
some of the most exquisite poetry that the young romantics have produced, which is Hymns to the Night. I mean, it's a cycle of six poems, and it's just absolutely stunning. And he plays with darkness and with death in a completely new way. So darkness becomes something positive. You know, before, darkness has always been something kind of scary. But I think he uses also his experiences from the minds, because in the minds you go into the bowels of the earth. And so the darkness becomes this metaphor for going into yourself, which, you know, is to this day a metaphor we use to us.
早期浪漫主义者创作的最为精美的诗歌之一，即《夜间颂歌》。我的意思是，这是一个由六首诗组成的组诗，简直惊艳绝伦。他以一种完全崭新的方式玩味黑暗与死亡。因此，黑暗变成了一种积极的东西。你知道的，在此之前，黑暗总是某种让人害怕的东西。但我认为他也运用了自己在矿井中的经历，因为在矿井里你要深入地球的腹地。因此，黑暗变成了探索内心深处的一种隐喻，你知道的，直到今天这仍然是我们所使用的隐喻。
But also he, I mean, it's interesting because he, presumably in the minds, I mean, he's seeing wheels turn and all this kind of stuff. But he has this complaint that nature, basically by Enlightenment philosophy, has been reduced to a monotonous machine, turning the eternally creative music of the universe into the monotonous clatter of a gigantic mill wheel. And that is a theme that is so important to the Romantics, isn't it? This rejection of the Enlightenment idea that everything is just cogs and wheels turning. Exactly. So they basically turn against these kind of mechanical models of the world. So you have, for example, Descartes, who declares all animals to be machines.
而且他也——我的意思是，这很有趣，因为他在矿井里，大概能看到齿轮在转动以及诸如此类的事情。但他有这样一种抱怨，即自然主义、启蒙哲学基本上将自然贬低成了一台单调的机器，把宇宙永恒创造的音乐变成了巨型磨盘单调的咔哒声。这是浪漫主义者极其重视的一个主题，不是吗？这种对启蒙运动“万物皆为齿轮与转轮”这一观念的拒绝？正是如此。所以他们基本上是在反抗这些对世界的机械化模型。所以，比如说笛卡尔，他宣称所有的动物都是机器。
And then obviously you have an increasing productivity. You have the enlightenment, you have steam engines, you have scientists who kind of peer through microscopes to understand the minutiae of life. You have them looking into the heavens to understand our place in the universe. You have physicians inoculating against smallpox. So the world becomes this measurable, repeatable, classifiable kind of machine. And that's what the romantics turn against. They don't turn against reason, but what they want is they want to poeticize the sciences. They want to stop this, what they say, this mill wheel, which kind of grounds itself to dust,
然后很显然，生产力在不断提高。你有了启蒙运动、蒸汽机、通过显微镜观察生命细微之处的科学家。你有了仰望星空以理解我们在宇宙中地位的人们。你有了为预防天花而接种疫苗的内科医生。因此，世界变成了一种可测量、可重复、可分类的机器。而这正是浪漫主义者所反对的。他们并不反对理性，但他们想要的是将科学诗意化。他们想要制止这种他们所说的“磨盘”——它会将自身研磨成尘埃，
because they believe that the Enlightenment has stripped the reality of the awe and wonder for nature. So what they really believe is that the external world has become something that has to be observed from a so-called objective perspective. And they say, and this is where Friedrich Schelling comes in with his philosophy, they basically say the self and nature is one. It's a unity. Everything is one big living organism. So if we are part of nature, if the system of nature and the system of the mind is the same thing, it means that when we walk through nature, when we walk through a forest or scramble up a mountain. It's always a journey of self-discovery. So this philosophy of oneness, that becomes the heartbeat of romanticism. That is the kind of the neck at the nexus of everything.
因为他们认为启蒙运动剥夺了现实对自然的敬畏与惊叹。所以他们真正坚信的是，外部世界已经变成了一种必须从所谓的客观视角去观察的事物。他们说——这就是腓特烈·谢林带着他的哲学登场的地方——他们基本上说，自我与自然是一体的。这是一个统一体。万物皆为一个巨大的活生生有机体。因此，如果我们是自然的一部分，如果自然系统与心灵系统是同一回事，这就意味着当我们漫步于大自然中，当我们穿过森林或艰难地爬上一座山时。这永远是一场自我发现之旅。因此，这种合一的哲学成为了浪漫主义的心跳。这就是一切的交汇点。
And that is what then becomes so important for the English romantics and for the American transcendentalists. The irony, though, is that, of course, they're talking all the time about unity, but they are incredibly divided among themselves, aren't they? I mean, you call them the Jaina set up with inflated egos, self-absorption and fight. And it's exactly what happens. They end up in what Dorothea Veidt calls a republic of despots. That's what they become. Right.
而这正是后来对英国浪漫主义者和美国超验主义者变得如此重要的东西。然而，具有讽刺意味的是，他们虽然一直在谈论统一，但他们内部却分歧巨大，不是吗？我的意思是，你把耶拿派称为一群自我膨胀、自我陶醉且充满争斗的人。而这正是所发生的事情。他们最终陷入了多萝西娅·弗伊特所称的“专制者共和国”。那就是他们最终的结局。没错。
But it's also, I mean, the arguments that they have are not merely arguments on the page, are they? So there's a scene in which students are throwing bricks through Fichte's windows because they despise his ideas so much. And Goethe says, you know, this is a very disagreeable way for Fichte to have the existence of a non-ich proven to him. So these are things that people are actually, I mean, maybe physically fighting is too strong an expression, but they are prepared to at least, if not to take up arms, then to take up bricks about. Yes. So, I mean, in the beginning, they kind of agree,
但这也是——我的意思是，他们的争论不仅仅是停留在纸面上的争论，对吧？所以有一个场景，学生们把砖头砸进费希特的窗户里，因为他们太鄙视他的观点了。歌德说，你知道的，这对于费希特来说是一种非常令人不快的方式，来证明一个“非我”的存在。所以这些是人们实际上——也许说他们在进行肉体搏击有点过头了，但他们至少准备好为此拿起砖头，如果不是拿起武器的话。是的。所以，我的意思是，一开始，他们还算意见一致，
but they're obviously fighting their literary establishment. And the literary establishment hates them. I mean, like hates them. They write satires about them. They write really, really savage reviews about them so but they it's almost like they're just fired up by this they just love it because and there's a wonderful quote where where august williams kind of says like they hate us great they curse us even better they you know they want to call us blasphemers even more fabulous so they quite like the fight. But then, in the end, they turn against each other.
但他们显然在与文学建制派作斗争。而文学建制派恨透了他们。我的意思是，简直恨透了他们。他们写关于他们的讽刺作品，写非常非常恶毒的书评来攻击他们。但这就好像他们被这些彻底激怒了，他们就是喜欢这样，因为有一个精彩的引言，奥古斯特·威廉在其中说：“他们恨我们？太棒了！他们诅咒我们？更好！他们想叫我们亵渎者？简直太美妙了！”所以他们其实挺享受这种斗争的。但最后，他们开始内讧了。
Yeah, it starts to kind of break up, doesn't it? Because Victor flounces off. I mean, he basically says, back me or I'm leaving. And they reduce the back him. The beginning of the breakup is really when Friedrich Schlegel very stupidly writes a savage or several savage reviews about Schiller's works, including criticizing Schiller's magazine Horen for having too many translations in there. But his brother himself wrote these, you know, these translations. So Schiller in the end just goes like, oh, my gosh, can't deal with these guys anymore. And he basically breaks off all contact.
是的，开始有点分崩离析了，不是吗？因为费希特一怒之下拂袖而去。我的意思是，他基本上说，要么支持我，要么我走人。而他们却减少了对他的支持。分裂的开始其实是腓特烈·施莱格尔非常愚蠢地写了针对席勒作品的一篇或多篇恶毒书评，其中甚至批评席勒的杂志《荷尔》里面有太多的翻译作品。但他自己的哥哥其实就写过这些——你知道的，这些翻译。所以席勒最后简直无语了，心想：天哪，我再也无法跟这帮人打交道了。于是他基本上切断了所有的联系。
And this is really when it starts because Schiller had originally brought them to Yale. So this is, and then you have Schiller who calls Caroline Madame Lucifer and Wilhelm von Homburg's wife calls her a snake. And it just goes on and on and on. And then they begin to- Well, women tend to be less keen on Caroline than men.
而这正是裂痕的开端，因为席勒原本是把他们带到耶拿的。所以这就是导火索，然后席勒把卡罗琳称作“路西法夫人”，威廉·冯·洪堡的妻子则叫她“毒蛇”。事情就这样没完没了地持续下去。然后他们开始——好吧，女性似乎比男性更不喜欢卡罗琳。
Would it be fair to say that's definitely fair to say and i think that that was because she never she was never willing to play the kind of demure domestic housewife she's you know she's always like i'm gonna hang out with a with a man here i'm gonna hang out yeah um one of my favorite bits in the whole book was when um and as you say they're always kind of flancing out and having bust-ups and writing negative reviews of each other in magazines and things and um schlegel announces that he's leaving one of them uh because dominic it was simply too embarrassing to write alongside so many inferior contributors oh my word tom so there's a there's something perhaps
如果说这是绝对公平的评价，那会很恰当吗？这绝对公平，我认为那是因为她从来——她从不愿意扮演那种娴静温顺的家庭主妇。她总是表现得像，“我要跟男人们混在一起，我要和他们去社交。”嗯，整本书里我最喜欢的片段之一就是，正如你所说，他们总是动不动就拂袖而去、大吵大闹，在杂志之类的地方写文章互相差评。然后施莱格尔宣布他要离开其中一个人，因为多米尼克，跟这么多平庸的投稿者并列署名实在是太尴尬了。天哪，汤姆，
for you to bear in mind um what with my podcast co-presenter are you serious i was thinking more of uh your many uh media you're thinking about other media outlets i am so but what about hold on what what about what about shelling when he gets a bad review suggesting to the editors that the only person who could write a review about his own book is himself. We all think that though, don't we? So Schiller has broken up with the kind of younger set. Fichte storms off and has to go off to Berlin. And then you mentioned Schelling and Schelling ends up married to Carolina.
所以也许有件事值得你记在心里，考虑到我的播客联合主持人……你是认真的吗？我其实想的是你的那些媒体……你想的是其他媒体渠道。我是认真的。但是，等一下，那谢林呢？当他收到一篇差评时，他竟然建议编辑说，唯一能写一篇关于他自己书的评论的人就是他自己。不过我们大家其实都这么想，不是吗？所以席勒已经和这群年轻人闹翻了。费希特气冲冲地离开，不得不前往柏林。然后你提到了谢林，而谢林最终娶了卡罗琳。
So that presumably also isn't, I mean, it's not hugely helpful to the group harmonies, is it? No, no. That is one of the other reasons why it kind of all breaks apart, but not so much, not because of August Wilhelm, who's married to Karoline, it's more because of Friedrich Schlegel, who used to be in love with Karoline, then gave her up for his brother. And then she just, you know, flounces off with the next one. So that's the moment when he, I think, gets so pissed off that he just, you know, all guards go down. And he and Dorothea just write so badly about Carolina, especially Dorothea, actually. Dorothea was, you know, she was not very beautiful.
所以这大概也——我的意思是，对群体的和谐并没有多大帮助，对吧？不，不。那是导致这一切最终分崩离析的另一个原因，不过与其说是由于奥古斯特·威廉——他和卡罗琳结过婚——不如说是由于腓特烈·施莱格尔。他曾经爱过卡罗琳，后来为了哥哥放弃了她。然后她却拍拍屁股跟下一个人跑了。所以这就是那个时刻，我想他气得肺都快炸了，以至于所有的防线都崩溃了。他和多萝西娅开始对卡罗琳恶言相向，特别是多萝西娅。多萝西娅其实——她长得并不算出众。
And she's the daughter of Moses Mendelssohn, right? Yeah, one of the greatest German Enlightenment philosophers. But she feels always a little bit, I think, overshadowed by Carolina because everybody just adored her. So the moment her lover turns against Carolina, Dorothea just writes an avalanche of horrible letters. I mean, when you read them, you think, oh, my God. And Carolina doesn't know that at the time.
而且她是摩西·门德尔松的女儿，对吧？是的，最伟大的德国启蒙哲学家之一。但她总是觉得自己，我想，被卡罗琳的光芒所掩盖了，因为所有人都太崇拜卡罗琳了。所以，当她的情夫背叛卡罗琳时，多萝西娅便写下了铺天盖地的可怕信件。我的意思是，当你读到这些信时，你会想：天哪。而卡罗琳当时根本不知道这一切。
She lives together with her and she's perfectly nice and friendly to her. So there's a lot of backstabbing going on at the end. And there's one other figure that we haven't mentioned. Again, I guess a household name, and that is Hegel, the philosopher Hegel. So he's not really part of the set, but he arrives towards the end, doesn't he? I suppose when they're in their falling out phase and when the glory days are slightly past. So do you see Hegel?
她和多萝西娅住在一起，对她非常好、非常友好。所以最后背后捅刀子的事情可真不少。还有另一个我们没有提到的人物。我想这也是一个家喻户晓的名字，那就是哲学家黑格尔。所以他其实不算是这个圈子里的人，但他是在接近尾声时才来的，不是吗？我想当时他们正处于决裂期，而且黄金时代也已经稍微过去了一点。所以你是怎么看黑格尔的？
I mean, so in many ways, I suppose you could say the ancestor of Marx and of so many kind of modern ideas. Do you see Hegel as part of this world as well? Well, Hegel is basically, he comes in, as you said, quite towards the end. And it's like, you know, he is, now he's this kind of towering figure. But then he's very much, so he had studied together with Schelling. And Schelling is the superstar. I mean, Schelling is made the youngest professor at the age of 23 in Jena.
我的意思是，在许多方面，我想你可以说他是马克思以及众多现代思想的先驱。你是否也把黑格尔视为这个世界的一部分？好吧，黑格尔基本上——正如你所说，他来得很晚。这就好像，你知道的，他现在是一个高耸的泰斗式人物。但在当时，他很大程度上——他曾和谢林一起学习。而谢林是超级巨星。我的意思是，谢林23岁就在耶拿成为了最年轻的教授。
And when Hegel arrives, it takes him like two or three years to make the decision to arrive. He ponders over everything. So as fast and restless as the others are, he's like very slow, kind of plodding along. And by the time he finally decides to come to Jena, the kind of whirlwind is kind of always blown out. But he comes to Jena to be with Schelling because, you know, Schelling is the kind of superstar. And then what happens is as he is in Jena, he moves away bit by bit from Schelling. So Schelling leaves in 1803.
当黑格尔到达时，他花了足足两三年才做出成行的决定。他对一切都反复权衡。所以，和那些动作迅速、焦躁不安的人相比，他是那种非常慢、笨拙前行的人。当他终于决定来到耶拿时，那种暴风骤雨般的狂热其实已经消散了。但他来耶拿是为了和谢林在一起，因为，你知道的，谢林是个超级巨星。然后发生的事情是，当他在耶拿时，他一点一点地疏远了谢林。所以谢林在1803年离开了。
And after that, Hegel really begins his own journey. And he turns against, in his philosophy, he really turns against all this kind of craziness and kind of philosophy, which loves art and imagination. And he says like, no, no, no. And he hates nature, doesn't he? Yeah, yeah. He goes to Switzerland and everybody's like in awe of the Alps.
在那之后，黑格尔才真正开启了自己的旅程。在他的哲学中，他真正开始反对所有这种疯狂的、热爱艺术与想象力的哲学，他说：不，不，不。而且他讨厌大自然，不是吗？对，对。他去瑞士旅行，所有人都对阿尔卑斯山惊叹不已，
And he's like more interested in the technique of Swiss cheesemaking. But what he says, he basically says, hold on. Philosophy is a serious business. So let's strip all that kind of art and imagination out of it again. So he is, he kind of ends it really. And there's this amazing scene, you know, where you sometimes think, you know, facts are just so much better than fiction, you couldn't invent it. So there's the Battle of Jena when Napoleon arrives with his 150,000 French soldiers and they descend onto Jena
而他却对瑞士奶酪制作的工艺更感兴趣。但他所说的是，他基本上说：等等。哲学是一件严肃的事情。所以让我们再次把所有那些艺术和想象力的东西从哲学中剥离出去吧。所以他——他实际上为这一切画上了句号。而且有一个令人惊叹的场景，你知道的，有时候你会想，现实往往比小说更精彩，你简直编不出来。那就是耶拿战役，当拿破仑带着他15万名法国士兵抵达并兵临耶拿城下，
and they destroy the kind of almighty Prussian army. And the day before the battle, you have Hegel with the manuscript of the Phenomenology of Spirit. It's his only copy. And he puts it on the stagecoach out of Jena. And then he sees Napoleon on a horse and calls him the world's soul.
他们摧毁了看似不可战胜的普鲁士军队。就在战役爆发的前一天，黑格尔手里拿着《精神现象学》的手稿。这是他仅存的一份复印件。他把它放上了驶出耶拿的驿马车。然后他看到骑在马上的拿破仑，称他为“世界精神”。
So it's this extraordinary moment, which is really, that's the end of Jena. Because after the battle, Jena is completely destroyed. The students all leave. But Hegel is there at the very last moment, like handing over his manuscript. So it's almost like a sort of harbinger of the herald of the 19th century at the end of the 18th, I guess, isn't he? I mean, sort of pointing ahead to the great ideologies
所以这是一个非凡的时刻，这真的是耶拿的终结。因为战役过后，耶拿被彻底摧毁了。学生们全都离开了。但黑格尔就在那个最后的时刻，赶着送出他的手稿。所以，他几乎就像是18世纪末迎来的19世纪的某种先驱或报信人，我想是的？我的意思是，有点像是在指向未来那些将主导未来的伟大意识形态。
that will dominate the future. It's an amazing moment actually because napoleon himself is a figure like that isn't he so napoleon himself is a sort of enlightenment figure who is anticipating but also a romantic figure that yeah but it's anticipating the dictators and the the you know the the the monstrous ambitions of the 20th century but he sees him as you, this is basically where this progression from like feudal system to democracies and freedom. He's basically the end of history for Hegel that when he sees him, he, you know, that because we think, oh, the French are, you know,
这其实是一个令人惊叹的时刻，因为拿破仑本人就是一个这样的人物，不是吗？所以拿破仑本人就是那种启蒙运动时期的人物，他既在展望未来，同时也是一个浪漫主义人物，对，但他预示着20世纪的独裁者和那些……你知道的……极其庞大的野心。但他把他看作——这基本上就是从封建制度向民主和自由演进的过程。对黑格尔来说，拿破仑基本上就是历史的终结，当他看到他时，他——你知道的——因为我们以为，噢，法国人在耶拿，德国人其实并不想这样。但有相当多的德国人希望法国人来，因为他们渴望获得解放。他们想生活在共和国里，而不是生活在专制统治下。所以黑格尔，尽管他的生命受到了威胁，但他还是希望法国人获胜。不过，安德烈，耶拿派基本上以所有人最终闹翻而告终。
in Jena, the Germans don't really want this. But there are quite a lot of Germans who want the French to come because they want to be liberated. They want to live in a republic and not in, you know, in absolutism. So Hegel, although his life is threatened, he wants the French to win. But Andrea, so the Jena set basically ends with that they all have bust ups.
他们全都各自逃跑，跟彼此结婚，最后互相痛恨。然后拿破仑出现，基本上把整个局面给砸个稀巴烂。但我从书中捕捉到的另一件事是，其中许多人物最终都极其猛烈地向右转。他们往往皈依天主教，往往在政治上变得相当反动。你认为这种狂热的 radicalism（激进主义）燃烧殆尽、逐渐消退、最后又转向反动的抛物线形轨迹——你认为这是否正在确立一种会被19、20世纪所遵循的原型？
They all run off and marry with one another and end up hating each other. And then Napoleon comes up and basically kind of trashes the whole thing. But one other thing that I picked up from the book is that a lot of these figures end up veering quite sharply to the right. So they tend to become Catholic, they tend to become quite politically reactionary. And do you think that that kind of parabola of kind of burning radicalism fading out, veering back into reaction? Do you think that that is that setting a kind of parabola of kind of burning radicalism fading out, veering back into reaction. Do you think that that is that setting a kind of prototype that will be followed through the 19th, 20th
我不知道。我认为这是不断在上演的事情，比如伟大的革命者往往会变成独裁者，变得具有民族主义倾向等等。所以我不知道他们是否算是一种原型。我想也许这正是人类的天性吧，也许吧。我担心的是——为了做个总结，让我们感受一下这究竟有多重要，因为我们的播客大约有一半时间都在谈论哲学，但另一半时间——恐怕全怪我——全都是关于……你可以看出汤姆的兴趣所在了。对。所以，对于那些可能对唯心主义哲学并非完全熟悉的听众来说，只需让我们感受一下这有多么重要，不仅对哲学而言，对整个欧洲历史的宏大走向而言。我认为他们基本上改变了我们的世界。事情就是这么简单。他们把“自我”放到了核心舞台上，无论好坏，它就一直在那里呆到了永远。
century? I don't know. I think it is something that happens all the time, like the big revolutionaries often become, you know, dictators and, you know, nationalistic and stuff like that. So I don't know if they're the prototype. I think it's maybe it's in human nature yeah maybe maybe i fear just just to sum up give us a sense of of just how significant this is because we've about half the podcast has been on on the philosophy but the other half i'm afraid it's entirely my fault has been all about the you can see where tom's interests lie yeah so just just just for people listeners who may not um be absolutely au fait with idealist philosophy, just give us a sense of how important this is, not just for philosophy, but for the whole sweep of European history. I think basically they changed our world. It's as simple as that. They put the self at center stage and it has stayed there for the better of the worst forever.
从他们把“自我”置于中心的那一刻起，我们——或者说人们——就不得不应对这种新获得力量的“自我”所带来的危险。而且，这就是我们今天依然不得不小心翼翼踩雷的同一种状态。我认为，正是它塑造了今天的我们。这一切始于启蒙运动，但这就是那个关键节点，这也是为什么我们今天会成为一个自私的社会，句号。我认为在某种程度上，就像现在，在这个当下，在我们今天生活的时代，你知道的，我们长期以来一直认为我们可以自由地思考、形成自己的观点、掌控自己的生活。但此时此刻，所有这一切——我们社会的核心——正受到极大的威胁，无论是通过俄罗斯对民主选举的网络干预，还是通过社交媒体上假新闻的“海啸”，或者右翼民粹主义政治运动。我们的民主制度此刻正被
And we have from the moment they put the self at the center, we had or people had to deal with the with the perils of this kind of newly emboldened self. And it is. It is the same kind of tiptoeing we still have to do today. And I think it is it has made us who we are. I mean, it starts with the Enlightenment, but this is the moment where this is why we are a selfish society today. Full stop. I think that in a way, like right now, in this moment, where we live today, you know, we have for long thought that we are free to think, to form our opinions, to control our lives. But right now, all of that, this very core of our society is very much under threat, be it through Russia's cyber interference in democratic elections, be it through the, you know, fake tsunami, the tsunami of fake news on social media or the kind of right-wing populist political movements. Our democracies are hollowed out right now through
骗子和平庸的暴君们掏空。所以现在是一个如此重要的时刻，让我们提醒自己，为什么——你知道的——我们是什么时候获得自由的？这种来之不易的自我决定权到底从何而来？所以在某种程度上，耶拿派赋予了我们心灵的翅膀，但我们如何使用它们，完全取决于我们自己。我对历史很感兴趣。我的意思是，你大概绝对会同意我的看法。历史不是一堆尘封的陈旧思想，它——你知道的——我对历史感兴趣是因为我想知道为什么我们成为了今天的自己。所以比如在写我的洪堡书时，我考察了人类与自然的关系，以理解我们为什么要摧毁我们的星球。而通过这本书，我真的很想知道：
liars and through despots. So I think right now is such an important moment to remind ourselves why, you know, when did we become free? Where does this hard-won self-determination came from? So in a way, the Jena set has given us our mind wings, but how we use them, that's entirely up for us. And I'm interested in history. And I mean, you will probably definitely agree with me. It's not like a dusty old pile of ideas. It's, you know, I'm interested in history because I want to know why we are who we are. So with my Humboldt book, for example, I looked at the relationship between humankind and nature to understand why we're destroying our planet. And with this book, I really wanted to know now,
为什么我们是一个如此自私的社会？这究竟是从哪里来的？哪里出了错？但也是为了提醒自己，你知道的，在耶拿派的语境下去做个“自私”的人其实是一件好事。这意味着你正试图让社会变得更好。它并不意味着去做一个自恋的混蛋。好吧，好吧，你绝对不会在我们的节目里请到那种人。安德烈，非常感谢你。这就是我在这期播客里的最后一句话：《光辉的反叛者》（Magnificent Rebels）。如果你想了解更多关于自恋混蛋的内容，你可以去读安德烈书：权力与幻觉的时代——早期浪漫主义者与自我的发明。他们可不仅仅是自恋的混蛋，对吧？他们绝对不是。他们远比那要宏大得多，对吧？他们确实如此。绝非如此。远比那要深刻得多。
why are we such a selfish society? Where does this come from? Where did it go wrong? And but also to remind myself that, you know, to be selfish in, you know, in the Yenaset meaning is something good. You know, it means that you are trying to make this, you know, to make society a better society. It doesn't mean to be a narcissistic asshole. Well, well, you definitely won't have people like that on our show. Andrea, thanks so much um magnificent rebels this is my very last sentence on this podcast if you want more about narcissistic assholes you can read andrea's book magnificent rebels the first romantics and the invention of the self and they're not just narcissistic assholes are they they are not at all very much more than are they? They are. Not at all. Very much more than that.
这是一本极其精彩、引人入胜的书。我完全收回我最初听说你要写这个主题时所表达的所有保留意见。这绝对是一部伟大的杰作。非常感谢你。也谢谢所有收听节目的听众。再见。
And it's a fantastically entertaining book. And I completely take back all the reservations that I expressed when you first said that this is what you were writing. It's an absolute triumph. Thank you so much. And thank you everybody for listening. Bye-bye.
谢谢。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前购买现场门票的特权，
Thank you. Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。